buried there so this model becomes the
African ancestry company - great
controversy on some parts so and the
sort of account that I tell I tell you a
bit about that story at the African
burial ground I talk as well about my
fieldwork with genealogist so this is um
in the foreground with the blue shirt is
a gentleman named Jaime Wilson who's an
African American geneticist at UMass
Lowell and the background is a
genealogist who's wearing sort of pure
colonial period costume at a genealogy
convention the reconciliation projects
also include a historic slavery
reparations case which I'll say
something about that begins in 2002 and
it takes me to and this is the first
vignette I'll tell you about - places
like the outskirts of Charleston South
Carolina
so in 2008 I received notice that a
group of people who identified as DNA
Sierra Leoneans we're going to
participate in asara SAR a a ceremony of
remembrance to rest the souls of their
ancestors the DNA Sierra Leoneans
included here the after Isaiah
Washington so some of you will recognize
from Grey's Anatomy at elsewhere and
some of the other people here there was
about 30 people gathered in total um
what's interesting about this photograph
is that the three people gathered here
all lay claim to Sierra Leone so Isaiah
Washington through genetic ancestry
testing that he results that he received
from the African ancestry company in
2004 he was given an award by a
pan-african Film Festival in Los Angeles
and as part of his swag bag for this
award he received a genetic ancestry
testing kit and as he would tell you
himself it sort of changed his life he
became a DNA Sierra Leone and based on
that experience the woman here is named
Tomalin polite she's a member of one of
the few African American families that
can trace their ancestry to the African
continent based on conventional records
and they've been slave manif slave ship
manifests and so sure family traces to
contemporary Sierra Leone through
conventional kind of brick-and-mortar
genealogy and history and the gentleman
here is a gentleman named Alma Dumas Ali
who at the time was a Sierra Leone
immigrant living in the United States
living in Dallas and fats who had come
to the to South Carolina on this day to
be the officiant at the ceremony so part
of what I want to suggest is that that
certificate of ancestry does things in
the world when it allows people to
gather who feel unsettled about the who
feel unreconciled and unsettled about
the history of the slave trade so i'ma
do Masoli here has soil from Sierra
Leone and he's casting it to the Ashley
River and on the just outside of
Charleston and the Ashley River was a
point of disome Bank meant for slave
ships in South Carolina so it has a very
important sort of geopolitical
significance
moreover some members of the community
including this gentleman who also
identified as a DNA Sierra Leonean put a
wreath and a wreath into the Ashley
River to commemorate and rest the souls
of the ancestors on both sides of the
Atlantic this was an interesting
occasion as well because it was just
down the road a couple miles with is the
Magnolia Plantation and the Magnolia
Plantation on this day was rededicating
some slave and sharecropping cabins as
part of a heritage tourism circuit and
so this event that only included about
me and 30 other people also included
these women who were historical
interpreters and sortable interpreters
at the Magnolia cabin so it was a very I
don't I hope you get a sense from these
photographs most of which I've taken
that it was a very surreal experience to
have women dressed in sort of slave
period dress DNA seer lunians and the
like but what I want to suggest is that
one of the ways that one of the sort of
projects of reconciliation for in which
genetic ancestry testing is used is in a
kind of spiritual communal way of sort
of communally wrecking together
reckoning together and in this case an
interracial group of people the history
of slave trade and what that means both
for this local community and more
generally secondly second been yet my
fieldwork introduced me to the work of
the Leon Sullivan foundation who some of
you might know so Sullivan was
philadelphia-based preacher he's
pictured here and he was involved in the
civil rights movement and he's pictured
here with Martin Luther King jr.
and it's interesting for all sorts of
reasons he might be known to some of you
because he was involved in answer your
part I'd activism of a sort a kind of a
corporate anti-apartheid activism that
led him to create what are called the
Sullivan principles which are static
opals for multinational companies
working abroad that are now are caught
and taught in business ethics classes
all over the United States and so in
1991
his organization his foundation the Leon
Sullivan foundation creates a series of
summits Sullivan writes he writes two
biographies autobiographies and he
writes about feeling having a messianic
vision that he's supposed to do work
that unites people of African descent
and the Americas and in Africa does
things to draw them together so for him
this was you know bringing businesses
you know helping to develop business and
philanthropy social and economic
development projects and he writes in
his one of his biographies I had heard
and heeded a call from God and from
Africa and African Americans and others
of the black diaspora to at least try to
unite people of African heritage with
Africa to make a link to build a bridge
he starts in part extending this vision
to hold these biennial gatherings called
Leon Sullivan summits that would take
place from 1991 through 2008 on the
African continent and would include
people like Paul Wolfowitz Condoleezza
Rice George HW Bush President Bill
former President Bill Clinton was an
honorary chairman of the board of the
Leon Sullivan foundation so lots of
American elites some of African descent
and African elites gathering to think
about development economic and social
development on the African continent so
the link the bridge that Sullivan writes
about that having this vision to draw
this Lincoln bridge for much of his life
was something that was just assumed that
people of African descent people of the
African Diaspora are related in 2008 the
Leon Sullivan foundation and Summit
passes a resolution that this bridge
or this link should be perhaps a genetic
one and so the organization encourages
the development and use of effective DNA
testing methods to identify specific
linkages to African ethnic groups among
members of the Diaspora so the
implication was that African Americans
should do sort of targeted philanthropy
targeted economic and social development
work based on the genetic ancestry
inferences that they would receive and
moreover that these tests might be used
to allow a sort of citizenship like
participation and African communities
for African on the part of African
Americans so this is the last year a
screenshot of the last Leon Sullivan
Summit which takes place in Arusha
Tanzania in 2008 and you see here that a
sponsor of this event is the African
ancestry company and this summit offered
as a registration option the ability to
sign up to get genetic ancestry testing
as an attendee and a delegate to this
convention secured okay well I was going
to show me see polish so as I said with
the sort of um the end game potentially
being some sort of form of citizenship
what I was trying to show you there was
just showed up on the screen and
disappeared here
it was the photograph of the Isaiah
Washington's Sierra Leonean Passport so
based on his genetic ancestry testing he
has dual citizenship in Sierra Leone so
that's another way that genetic ancestry
testing is being used beyond the family
identity that I think we get used to
seeing on these reality television shows
people are using it to form new kinds of
relationships and affiliations in the
world and it's certainly the case that
consumers genealogists you have this
experience they often travel it's one of
the things they do with the information
they have - the African continent or
elsewhere where they've - places where
they've been inferred to be related and
part of this now includes visits with
various Chiefs and various of
communities on the African continent
that offer various forms of affiliations
such as renaming ceremonies and the like
so we also found not only genetic
ancestry testing but the ancestry the
the services of the African ancestry
company appear much to my surprise and a
historic 2002 class-action suit for
reparations for slavery farmer Pillman
vs. fleet Boston so some of you will
recall this probably will recall this
case from over a decade ago that begins
over a decade ago in which a series of
multinational corporations including CSX
Lloyd's of London jr. Reynolds fleet
Boston were being sued for slavery
reparations based on the sort of idea
that these were companies that profited
variously from the rate from the slave
trade and then that still exist today in
part based on the wealth and profits
that were gained from insuring enslaved
people as property on the part of their
owners transporting them on cxx trains
and these sorts of things right so
there's the case is dismissed Joe but in
2004 there's an early dismissal there
were a couple of conditions or a couple
of dismissed without prejudice and one
of the critiques of the case was that
the people didn't have the plaintiffs
didn't have standing
they weren't the injured parties who can
prove that they had standing to bring
this court to case this case to court so
this is the lead plaintiff Diedra former
PL menhir pictured with one of her
attorneys one of her other attorneys was
Edward Fagin who had a couple of years
before been successful in getting
reparations for Holocaust survivors from
the Swiss government so they're told in
2004 that the plaintiffs cannot
establish a personal injury sufficient
to confer standing by merely alleging
some genealogical relationship to
formerly enslaved persons effectively so
farmer Palin goes to the African
ancestry company in Washington DC at her
and another of the plaintiffs they buy
eight of these test kits and they do
mitochondrial and Y chromosome DNA
testing and they enter these as evidence
in this civil tort case to prove that
they have standing that they're the
injured parties that have standing
so to the best of my knowledge this is
the first time that genetic ancestry
testing is interested introduced as
evidence and the court case at all to
the best of my knowledge certainly the
first time in a court case or a civil
case that wasn't about sort of family
issues or paternity so for reasons that
route that may not surprise you
it doesn't quite do the job so there's a
second dismissal in 2005 again with
without prejudice which means they can
sort of regroup and the court basically
says to appellate courts that genetic
mapping or DNA testing alone is
insufficient to provide a decisive link
to homeland so these are very long
decisions the 2004 dismissal is about 75
pages this 2005 dismissal is about 100
pages for those of you who are
interested in genetics in the law I
would highly recommend that you read the
birth day the case findings are
fascinating and they're you know they
come to us sort of six or seven years
but for the myriad genetics Supreme
Court case so here you have a lower
court trying to reckon with whether or
not genetic genealogy is the same as
genealogy and so they're very
interesting sort of discussions and
these and these dismissals and this last
dismissal basically says that genetic
ancestry testing or genetic genealogy
and sort of conventional genealogy are
sort of parallel but not similar right
that they're sort of operating like this
and that they couldn't provide genetic
ancestry testing the specificity the
kind of genealogical specificity that
the court would need to advance such a
case so you would need basically to be
able to go back to an ancestor
genealogically names right and to also
go back to you know the corporation's
right back in time and these things
these lines would be to be unbroken and
genetic ancestry testing although it's
getting more powerful at helping us to
identify individuals certainly could not
do this in 2005 so the case is not
successful but I think arguably it
continues a long conversation as I write
that starts you know hundreds of years
ago about what is what might be owed to
enslaved Africans in their descendants
because of the history of the slave
trade that of course comes to light
again in 2014 with taught to not tonic
ICI coats very important and also
historic in its own way cover story in
the Atlantic about slavery reparations
so this is another piece another way in
which genetic ancestry testing is used
to kind of if we go back to the
descendant of venture Smith Florence
Warmsley do healing in our country in
ways I think that are quite surprising
the other thing I think that's quite
interesting about this case is that here
you have in 2004 just a few years into
the introduction of genetic ancestry
testing in the United States and not
quite a full year into the emergence of
the African ancestry company you know
activists sort of seizing on a new
technology to try to get leverage and a
very long-standing controversial debate
and American politics
so to wind down a little bit I want to
tell you lastly about another vignette
from my ethnography that brought to me
again a sense that that we're trying to
do something quite powerfully symbolic
and around reconciliation and race in
this country with genetic ancestry
testing in part because the tests allow
us I think to think historically about
the present right so to be able to say
to a friend or colleague that you have a
genetic ancestry and France that infers
you to be related to a people that you
would have been related to before the
Middle Passage or before slavery is to
suggest that slavery it sort of lives
today it's after-effects in the
contemporary moment in the 21st century
with your neighbor with your friend with
yourself and I think it's a way to sort
of push the envelope or force
conversations forward when though when
others want to say well that happened so
long ago who did it really affect it has
nothing to do with you it has nothing to
do with me you know the tests are used
to sort of bring that to the floor bring
into relief that history so one of the
other reasons I start to do this
research is that you know I'm quite
skeptical I suggest this in the
beginning
I'm skeptical because I do wonder why
African Americans would be what some
might regard as sort of fast and loose
with their tissue with genetic samples
putting
in the mail and and also because I think
you know I'm somebody who hadn't sort of
felt for myself a kind of deep learning
of the type that many of the people I
interviewed over the course of the last
decade about African ancestry so as I
and this was also a research project
unlike the first book that I wrote in
which the technology and the sort of
social practice was evolving quickly as
I was doing the research and so I found
myself in the position of writing papers
and giving talks as I was doing the
research just kind of one step ahead but
what's happening and often in these
experiences people would say to me you
know I'm in the course of a QA well
what's your test result and what did you
do and what was your experience and so I
wasn't particularly interested in that
but as an ethnographer my legitimacy
really depends on sort of not the big
large end of my sample but the depth of
my sample and my ability to really sort
of drill down into conversations with
people and these meanings that it has
for them so I found myself compelled to
I think by the own at the ethics of my
own research to have a genetic ancestry
test so I think to myself I'm gonna do
it I'm gonna do a reveal right at this
point reveals have been become a big
part of genetic ancestry testing so I
had planned actually to go to what would
have been the 2010 Leon Sullivan Summit
after the 2008 after the 2008 one which
the resolution was passed to encourage
African Americans to do genetic ancestry
testing and it gets cancelled for all
sorts of reasons Leon Sullivan
foundation gets into a little political
trouble and sort of you know sort of
wanes and sort of it has now come back
so instead they have what they call an
Africa Policy Forum in September of 2010
it takes place in the week after the UN
General Assembly here in New York City
and it takes place in Atlanta and it the
timing is such that there were lots of
African politicians and diplomats
bureaucrats who were still in the United
States because they'd been here for the
UN General Assembly so I decide I'm
going to get my reveal on this evening
at the summer of 2010 I send in my
genetic ancestry on my tissue sample put
it in the envelope send it to African
ancestry for one test two mitochondrial
DNA test
this is in a June in August I receive an
email from the Leon Sullivan Foundation
saying that the reveal ceremony has
become royal so it's an email with just
all caps and it says on this evening the
DNA of that shirt the African tribe or
the nation-state I think this tribe that
can claim the king claimed Martin Luther
King jr. will be revealed so I thought I
was doing a public reveal it turned into
being what the African what the Leon
Sullivan Foundation calls a royal reveal
so I would to other African American
women turn out to be the opening act for
a kind of performance of genetic
ancestry testing reveals and racial
reconciliation so this is a photograph I
took from that evening there's Isaiah
Washington who's the evening who's the
emcee that evening and the photograph I
was going to show you of his passport
was taken that evening he had it in his
breast pocket a Sierra Leonean passport
and it was dog-eared and you know I said
why would you be carrying your Sierra
Leonean passport and Atlanta and he said
these are my freedom papers quite
pointedly and he's pictured of course
next to Rick Kittles so I get my reveal
and you know as I try to write in the
book it was a bit awkward because I felt
that I couldn't probably perform this
sort of effect and emotion that we've
come to expect on genetic geneology
reality television shows but I do okay
and everyone was there in the end to see
some more interesting reveals so this is
a the son of Marcus Garvey his name is
Julius Garvey he is a retired cardiac
surgeon who lives on Long Island he's a
pretty you know then assuming you know
senior african-american senior citizen
the only thing that would give away I
think his father's politics is on his
lapel there's a pen of the pan is a red
black and green a pan-african pen that
subtly sort of tells you who whose
progeny he is and the other reveal was
the son of Martin Luther King Jr Martin
Luther King the third who's pictured
here with his sister that's Isaiah
Washington there Rick Kittles this is
hope masters who's the daughter of Leon
Sullivan now deceased and Gina page who
African ancestry with Rick Kittles so
what's fascinating is that they are the
both feets Y chromosome of Garvey's son
and Martin Luther King son
traced to Europe and the mitochondrial
DNA traced to Africa and so you have
them I find out later that they were
told the results in advance and so they
are allowed to speak about what the
results mean to them and Garvey's son as
you wouldn't be surprised to hear sort
of talks about the history of the
transatlantic slave trade and how it's
the brutality of this history the sexual
violence of this history that makes his
Y chromosome trace to Europe
unsurprising to him Martin Luther King
the third sort of ways and more subtly
on these same points but pivots to kind
of tell a sort of narrative about how
we're all related and that we it's
important that we sort of face this
history so when I'm trying to suggest in
with this moment by 2010 as I'm you know
really sort of wrapping up sort of
winding down in the last sort of quarter
of my research is that we are turning to
genetics and genetic analysis to answer
all sorts of questions so rather that be
whether that be Brian Sykes work about
the the Russians arena right the or the
question about you know what the
identity of bog man might be these sort
of historical questions that were
answering or these questions about
racial reconciliation so the symbolism
of having the scions the sons of these
race leaders have their genetic ancestry
tests and reveal this evening and what
it helped ibly meant to the audience we
thought much like I think the descendant
of venture Smith that we were doing
something that night what in these
reveals were sort of caring for a kind
of healing so there's lots of other
stories that I narrate in the book that
really drive this point home but for me
this is a really a poignant story
because I think that fundamentally we
need to do the hard work of having
conversations about the racial
inequality and about the past of this
country and many countries and where I
end up is for different reasons
on the same page with alvin weinberg the
late scientist physicist who comes up
with this concept of the trans scientist
so for him it was really meant to
distinguish politics from science and a
very sort of strict way scientists do
one thing politicians or another thing
and never the twain should be so at the
sociologists of science I understand
these things to be sort of intertwined
all the time right and all sorts of ways
funding decisions citation you know the
questions that people choose to ask but
when Weinberg offers for us is is among
other things this sort of I think an
important point which is that we think
science and we know science is so
powerful that we pose our most important
questions to it but these might not be
the questions that science can answer
right so he says that the trans
scientific there are questions in the
world that can be asked of science yet
which cannot be answered by science I
proposed the term trans scientific for
these questions since they are
epistemological speaking questions of
fact and can be stated in the language
of science they are unanswerable by
science they transcend science and what
I want to suggest is that these are
well-meaning efforts these
reconciliation projects to get genetics
to help us do the work of having the
conversations the acknowledgment such
this sort of grieving difficult
conversations that might look something
more like a truth and reconciliation
process than the silver bullet of a
genetic test and so I think the
reconciliation projects mostly remain
unresolved until we're willing to have
those difficult conversations so I thank
you for your attention and I look
forward to your or your feedback thank
you very much so we have a c-span crew
here so if you have questions or
comments you'll need to come to the mic
if you would
I guess I have a sort of concern or a
comment about the idea that a person
would get a statement saying that
they're from ancestry from Sierra Leone
I mean if you've got like say eight
generations in North America that's 256
ancestors there really can't be a place
you are from if you're that far back
sure on the side of that so what is it
how do you just feel free uncomfortable
to say yeah well it can't be true
sure any scientific sense sure I think
it's it's uncomfortable scientifically
and also historically but it's very
powerful and meaningful socially for
communities that have don't have access
to other information right so adoptees
people of African descent who literally
don't have records or other ways to even
know right and so that the sort of
response when I posed quite a similar
question to the people that I
interviewed would be you know this is
better than no information of all so of
course like if the alternative is what I
have now which is nothing I'm willing to
you know enter into this endeavor to
find out a little bit something
recognizing that it might have both
scientific and historical limitations so
but your points that well taken and true
hi good evening the word reconciliations
is just interesting to me because I am
just getting around to getting my DNA
done and for my parents as well because
they're older and mine was a little bit
different only because my family is from
the Caribbean rather than here in these
United States where slavery just took on
a different kind of face where people
were really in Africans who were
enslaved were just taken someplace had
their names changed sometimes at the
grille of them of the owner so that a
lot of times if the lease for paperwork
it's almost impossible but some people
have done a really good job
you've been mentioning stuff this
happens in in 2010 this is now 2016 so
there's been a lot of progress since
then I still want to know if Isiah
Thomas did it again will he still be
just Sierra Leone when I've had my
parents done my mother came out 99%
African she was from st. Croix so there
and the again the the way that slavery
happened people weren't didn't have
their names change that the inter
mixtures didn't weren't quite as
expansive and everything but but I still
think that you're right when you're
saying that it's going to take a lot of
talk I think a lot some I think as
people do it and I really think at this
point it's more on African Americans or
people of African descent who are really
working on this because we want to find
out where we're from we've taken the
whole continent of Africa so we are not
Swedish American or a Spanish American
or Italian Americans all the specific s
they have their own ethnic groups but
they're a particular place and so when
we're taking Africa which is a continent
not a country that's where we get kind
of low loss that but I have friends who
whose families are here and they have
met the so-called the white people of
their family and some of some of those
meetings have gone well and some of them
have not going well so that's where
you're talking about the kinds of
conversations that people need to have
but for me and my family right now is
I'm the one that's doing the push it's
like just to find out where we're from
we're not really looking for any anybody
else but it's like where are we from
you know so that's where this
reconciliation is for me and my family
sure yes thank you so I'll just offer a
few observations thank you very much for
those comments um you know one I would
say that I have a worked with a small
group of people black Britons and London
and there
surrounding areas who had participated
in an early that a documentary on the
BBC called motherland that runs
occasionally here in the United States
on the Africa Channel but really
proceeds all of the shows that we have
in the United States on genetic ancestry
testing and so it's a group of about
three hundred people they're given Y
chromosome and mitochondrial DNA
analysis and then three of them are
chosen to be brought back to the places
that they're inferred to be from and so
but the group sort of stays together as
a group and the directors and producers
of this show do a really good job of
keeping them together as a group and
getting them lots of information so
scientists from University of Leicester
the University of Oxford would come and
talk to them regularly about scientific
research and genetics but one of the
things that was interesting about this
sample versus the sample of mostly
African Americans I spoke to is that
most of them were part of what's called
the Windrush generation and mid 20th
century generation and the UK that came
from places like Ghana and Barbados and
Jamaica and there was a smaller set of
them I mean many of them spoke about
people in their family not being
interested because they identify very
strongly with what I call in another
place the kind of black geography right
so they you have a place like Jamaica
like Barbados where you can say you're
from that has a kind of distinctive
culture not that african-americans do
not write but that sort of in some ways
for some fuels that fills the place of
what African Americans are trying to
accomplish you know certainly it's true
that as the country the industry has
evolved that the databases are getting
bigger where it be able to testing for
more markers the types of tests have
changed so you know to get a test result
that's 90 percent African which I can't
imagine your family member found very
satisfying but is you know imagining
admixture testing we now have exome
testing and then some some ability to do
a kind of whole genome testing those for
those people who can afford it or in the
sort of PGP these sort of different
projects that allow that to take place
so the databases are always changing the
markers are changing are the algorithms
are changing so it's definitely
something that's moving and what's
getting interesting and I was gesturing
to when I was talking a bit about the
reparations pieces that it is getting a
bit easier not easy but easier to upload
ones markers if you use a service that
will give you your your markers to a
third-party app like one called Gini ve
nie which you can look and see if you
have matches with other genealogists and
they can open their family tree you know
some people have done that that becomes
really interesting because people don't
have to open their tree to you and I
interview people who talk about being
frustrated by the person that they think
they have some matches with on open the
family tree so they can't get more
information so there's an interesting
kind of exchange that has to take place
among people so yeah so there's just a
few by way of response to a few of the
comments that you made thank you for
them comment in a question it seems to
me that obviously everybody has a basic
interest in knowing who they are and
where they're going I mean Paul Gauguin
phrase that so well in that painting
with the French phrases that I can't
paraphrase but I'm concerned about the
issue of so I'm wondering about the
agenda people use to get this
information I mean you yourself said
that you had no interest in testing
until you felt you how to legitimize
your own studies and I'm wondering if
the same thing hold true with people
having so many diverse motivations to
get this information and how many of
them really interested in the concept of
reparations reparations is a very fuzzy
area no question that slavery was a
horrible thing in this country we have a
250 year history of that but I could
argue if you're talking about
reparations Sephardic Jews could go back
to 1492 or English Jews could go back to
the 13th century when they were expelled
for me when in fact 1,200 something so
how far do you define this and where
does it end it's very confusing to me
Commodore yeah thank you for that I mean
I would say an answer I mean I'm only
suggesting that eight people the eight
plaintiffs in this class action suit are
interested in reparations actually but I
would say that the many of most of the
rest of the people I talk to you are
interested in some form of
reconciliation so whether that is having
a sense of who
of a pre middle passage identity sort of
who are my diaspora people and a more
specific sense than a continental
identity as you said madam or this sort
of spiritual ceremony that I showed you
that that there are people are engaged
in social practices that are more than
just about the sort of facts of identity
trying to give them new ways to be in
the world with us in with this new
information so you know I I would only I
would I don't have a problem saying you
know there are eight people interested
in reparation although using genetics
although I'm sure there's probably many
more but in my sample there's eight but
there are you know hundreds who are
interested in various forms of
reconciliation and just even if that
just means trying to wrap their heads
around for themselves and their family
the legacy of slavery and what that
means
hi thank you so much for giving this
talk today I'm a first year medical
student I'm actually here but where are
you at school up mont sinaï okay
and so in medicine some of the things
that we've been taught about includes
genetic testing with regards to live
more specifically race but now there's
more talk of it being based on ancestry
but in alternative spaces other students
and i have been exploring issues where
um we have a lot of concerns and we've
looked at at the work of like dorothy of
Dorothy Roberts another who just had a
great paper in science write about this
sort of suggesting that we shouldn't use
race at all with regard to genetics
mmm-hmm but there's some there's a lot
of talk about how ancestry is being used
as euphemism for raising and reaffirming
race-based genetics and what does that
mean for disease and health disparities
um I think a big concern is um it's
pointing to genetics as a way to explain
disease in a way that ignores social
factors right I'm also in a way I know
something I'm thinking about too is how
racism is used to blame people for
disease but specifically back patients
and what does it mean when we only point
to alleles to talk about as evidence for
disease and ignoring a lot of the other
social historical and structural factors
that that leads to these conditions and
I'm just wondering if this came across
and your research or if you have any
thoughts about it or what should we keep
in mind maybe a future position well you
you raised so many issues so eloquently
it's hard to add much more to that so
you're gay
a very fine education at Sinai for sure
medical curriculum is okay right so sure
I mean I guess I don't for a couple of
metres offer you an event yet and then I
sort of more direct answer so this is
course is one of my questions as well I
mean you know I come into sort of my own
as a graduate student as a scholar when
we're getting very important historical
writing about the history of scientific
racism we have a whole series in the 90s
in particular fantastic monographs that
are really sort of opening up that space
of inquiry for scholars and so I came to
this project with those reservations
what I thought was really fascinating
and I write about this with regard to
the African burial ground project is
there's a group of activists who are
working with African American
geneticists and biological
anthropologists and social scientists
there who say that this is this grave
site in lower Manhattan here is a very
historic one because it's one of the
biggest sites that we have and the
ability to get information about the
experienced of colonial Africans in New
York enslaved Africans was a very rare
and important one and up into this point
it was it's this is the biggest cemetery
of enslaved persons other than one that
had been found in Philadelphia a few
years prior to this and sort of the late
80s so it was a very important sort of
historical site and initially the
remains were went to Lehman College to a
laboratory there and were being analyzed
by scientists you were more like
forensic scientists who were not
particularly interested in the history
of the remains they weren't interested
in whether necessarily interested in
whether the remains were buried with
cowrie shells how you know were the
burials were the bodies buried or not
where they're facing Mecca or not you
know what was the material culture in
them so to become some of you might
recall a big sort of controversy and
social mood of social movement activism
around the African burial ground and
part of this is around the politics of
knowledge so who is what's the best team
and the best kind of analysis for those
remains and so you have some well
trained scientists but you also have
activists people who are lay people
African Americans saying we think it's
okay to use
genetic analysis craniometry dental
morphology on these remains because we
want to find information that about our
ancestors that we might not be able to
get otherwise but we want a team that's
going to think about the historical
questions and gonna think about the sort
of material culture questions and so
this is part of the conversation in
which these remains leave Lehman College
and become a project at Howard
University for all sorts of historical
and political reasons there's a kind of
identity politics around that move but
what's interesting to me about that case
is that you have activists saying we
want to use these new forms of analysis
if we can figure out a D in ancient DNA
to use as a type of analysis we want to
use it but we don't want it to result in
the biological racing that's a literal
biological Racing's verbatim quote of
our ancestors remains so here you have a
group of people some experts some
laypeople
drawing a fine line between the use of
genetic analysis to do race making or
kind of race claim rate racial
classification of a kind of harmful way
and the ability to use those to make
other kinds of claims right so you know
I think reasonable people can agree
about whether or not that was a
successful strategy but I just want to
suggest that it's I guess it's not the
case that the people that I talked to
were sort of dupes or didn't understand
about that history or didn't understand
the risks that were engaged in sort of
participating in a conversation that
says genetics can say something about
ancestry and I think the response to
that sort of sort of also came in the
choices that people made about the test
that they chose right so you know they
chose many people said I'll use the
African ancestry company because I
really trust dr. Kittles other people
would say I'm doing admixture testing
because I think that my family has
theirs like people from newer Malagasy
and some who are Europe and we're trying
to figure out this mixture that a lot of
their questions sort of shape the test
that they use and the choices that they
made around the consumption of
direct-to-consumer tests so I'll just
offer that as I kind of been yet to
suggest that there's I think that
sometimes our critique
around a sort of 21st century
articulation of scientific racism
assumes a kind of naivete on the part of
the people are participating and they're
a bit more sophisticated so I just want
to sort of put that piece out there but
that said you know we we do run that
risk I mean you know race is a social
construction our bodies look different
because of biology and genetics but
there's no natural way or natural way
that we should sort of give that
hierarchy and classification and meaning
in the world we do that we make we've
made it in the past we make it every day
we make those things mean things so I
think but but it still might be the case
that you know the genetics might be able
to be a part of you know an approach to
ending health disparities it can't be
the only answer obviously right but you
know it's it's it's certainly worth
considering whether it can be the piece
you know one piece and a larger strategy
that takes you know seriously whether or
not people have food security housing
clothing you know the health leads
program is interesting you know is
interesting and sort of prescribing food
and housing for people as part of the
work that they do so that's just a sort
of way of being in conversation with you
and underscoring the points that that
you make and I think that you know as
genetic research you know who knows what
epigenetics will yield but you know to
the extent that a field like epigenetics
really forces us to deal with
gene-environment interaction and that
these things aren't stable right that
there are kind of moments of triggers of
off and on and also that the environment
matters right so to come from that
research I think we must have right if
you know even people who claim that they
are sort of genetic determinists right I
think must come away from that with sort
of understanding that social factors
social determinants matter for health
and a really kind of fundamental way
hello hi so I just wanted to take the
conversation back to us the idea of like
reparations and how this would affect
that so I'm gonna give a little personal
history and get to my question so me my
dad is from Antigua and my mom like
we're from Miami so her mom is from
Panama and her dad is from Georgia so
right they're like african-american
that's like a quarter so in addition to
that people my family have kids late and
then they live like forever like they
just keep going there might be some
geneticists in this room that wants to
talk to you mom had me like in her late
30s and then like my grandfather
so my granddad she died at like 106 or
so so they're just this thing alive and
her grandparents are her parents are
sold with sharecroppers the point that
I'm trying to make is that from my
family like the stretch between here and
there isn't that many generations and so
now my question comes back to that and
it's if reparations were to happen what
do you think the genetic testing would
come down to say who like if there is
money to be had or if if if people are
to get something how does that then get
divvied out because I mean I'm black but
said white person to be just as black as
me I think but not physically black so I
mean when it comes down to genetics we
could be in the same family but then
it's like as the reparations from
slavery or is it for all those things
that happen because we might genetically
both be white or black but because I
still look like I've had these different
things up until today right so when it
comes down to divvy out I already know I
mean I'm only getting a quarter just
based on
just based on that I mean that's like
3/4 right then in the US yes so once you
get down to it and then because of you
know the way it happened in America you
know there's Whitesides your family
black sighs I feel like there's so much
more mixing than maybe happened in the
Caribbean where it's very much you
showed up in Antigua and you stayed
there until you left so I just want to
get your thoughts on that yeah it's a
great question I mean you know it wasn't
until I started doing this work and
found out that these tests appeared in
this reparation as part of the
back-and-forth the chess game of this
reparations slavery lawsuit that I have
actually thought deeply or read deeply
about reparations activism in the United
States so and so you know that that's
that's a question and I think that a lot
of the answers that certainly some of
these activists in the suit deed
reformer Pillman might say is that it's
not about divvying up to individuals
right these are about kind of structural
adjustment sort of structural changes
structural resources for schools you
know for education for health care to
sort of raise the bottom rather than
being too specific individuals however
what's interesting about her approach so
she farmer Pellman goes to law school
because she's interested in seeing if
there could be a legal approach to to
advance a reparations case and she sort
of decides upon trying to advance this
genealogical strategy but what that what
she's sort of tied into what they're
tied into when they commit themselves
through genealogical strategy is having
to show you know me you know parent
grandparent great great great great
grandparent and also simultaneously the
specific companies right so this
specific great-great great grandparent
insured by Lloyds of London right and
then sort of carrying that down you know
sort of the line of wealth and the line
of genealogy so you know if someone
weren't able to bring a case like that
claim you know that's so specific one
you know probably you know a one
wouldn't have to be a Nobel
prize-winning economist I think to be
able to make a calculation someone could
say how many slaves were insured but the
coin and you know sort of calculate that
forward so you know I think there's lots
of different strategies but certainly
you know there is no african-american
gene and so you know to sort of
differentiate that and sort of divvy up
to use your words is all but impossible
but it's a very complicated question and
I think it's probably a conversation
worth having and what I was struck by in
doing this research which I hadn't this
reading on reparations that I hadn't
read about before is that it's just been
this on going for hundreds of years
debate and conversation you know and one
does wonder if you know Tana hi-c code
says this in his Atlantic essay you know
is it time to let John Conyers bill to
just have a conversation right it's a
bill to have to have a committee have a
conversation about reparations you know
is it not time just to have that
conversation right it's not a bill that
says you know we're gonna divvy up again
to use your phrase or make any kind of
take any kind of action but literally
just to open up a conversation and you
know I think it's not you know it's
something about speculatively but not a
hugely but you know part of what we've
been seeing the distress that we've been
seeing in our communities all over the
United States around sort of race and
policing and racial inequality also I
think have to do in part there's lots of
reasons right as a sociologist I know
this but our sort of fundamental
inability to say like something is
broken and we need to sort of stop and
try to fix it so you know I don't know
if reparations is that fixed but to the
extent but I think some form of
reconciliation or conversation and I
really gimlet-eyed look on the part of
all of us about where we are as a
society I think is is well worth asking
for
hello hi thanks for the really
insightful talk Tulane is our drama
family position my background in
sociology so I'm definitely very
interested in identity and actually my
family is from Ghana so in that regard I
I wanted to know if you have any
commentary about how samples and of
genetic the genetic database has been
obtained and you know in on the
continent at one point I had read about
some kind of ethical issues with how
they're presenting you know West
Africans and central Africans with the
prospect of you know submitting these
samples and then from my perspective
even though I'm aware of okay I wish I
could take this down but I'm aware of
you know my my my heritage my parents
are fancy but at the same time we also
have kind of like a history beyond you
know the borders of Ghana like saying my
you know my mom has talked about oh you
know our family migrated from the north
that could be like Mali or you know so
so even I'm like a you know actually
interested if in testing this journey
about because I know now some tribes can
be identified well I guess it depends I
don't know if the African Andros
ancestry identified well it doesn't
identify tribes correct yeah based on
janym janym standard tandem repeat
markers using Y chromosome and
mitochondrial I mean you know it's it's
a pretty an exact science but mm-hmm
and then another comment is I'm curious
as as genetic testing taking off in the
Caribbean because I mean I someone
mentioned about that there's there's
less there was less race mixing and in
the West Indian West Indies but my
impression was that it's kind of very
similar to the United States so you know
I actually lived in Dominica for two
years and I mean just I've visit so many
islands so there you know racial mixing
as a result of slavery is just as
extensive or maybe even more so the
United States so lots there
[Music]
you might tell me that Roux might be the
first piece I've sorry I got so
captivated by the ook that well affected
my family's from Ghana and I had read
about some kind of ethical issues that
oh yes yes your staff were raised in
regards to how they example have been
obtained and uh yeah great yeah so so
yeah this is a fascinating question that
comes up quite a bit because it sort of
suggests who benefits right by this you
know authenticating these wherever they
are databases whether they're you know
African DNA at Family Tree DNA or
African ancestry so Rick Kittles does an
interesting thing I mean he has samples
in his lab when he starts this reference
database he gets you know cyan bench
scientists swap genetic samples all the
time and he also was using sort of
GenBank which had a sort of like an
atlas of mitochondrial DNA marker so
that's how he did it and then for a time
he was doing some basic sort of health
care provision so he would go to health
clinics and West's places in West Africa
and would take tissue samples in
exchange for you know giving
immunizations or other sorts of things
so I think that's you know one of the
ways but I think for you know African
American consumers who are concerned
about having a sort of ethical
relationship to you know can people on
the African continent it's a question
you know worth asking I mean I don't I
don't think there's a lot of
transparency around where the samples
come from and so yeah so that's a you're
exactly right that it's in I mean it's
not a bio ethical conundrum and that
it's sort of breaking some regulatory or
kind of moral code in that way but
there's an exchange happening there and
it's an uneven exchange right in lots of
ways because you know why there might
have been some immunization given or
something for a sample it's not that
people are continuing to necessarily
sort of benefit from that giving that
the tissue over this on the other hand I
would say you know I have a graduate
student who works on gone on heritage
tourism in Ghana and he's been really
interested in how
the guy and state has been increasingly
incorporating heritage tourism as part
of its sort of GDP calculations there
was a significant part of its of its
budget and I think it's called the it's
called the Joseph project but there was
a kind of project that was modeled on I
think an Israeli project that was you
know similar sort of pillars of had
about the Diaspora for a time the Joseph
project included it's sort of a proposal
to incorporate genetic analysis as part
of this so I mean you know one could
argue that you know part of what sort of
dots the eye across with the tea on the
ethical or closes the loop on the
ethical exchange is that as I said it's
very often the case that African
Americans do you know they travel or
they donate or you know there's there's
not quite a remittance culture but it
does sort of I think inspire people to
do have forms of affiliation that might
have sort of financial benefit to people
around the world but I think it's I
think it's a pretty fundamental question
that you raise though and you're right
about the Caribbean I mean you know the
certain you know Haiti Dominica of
course Trinidad you know there's there's
color and caste and all of these island
nations that have very much to do with
history of slavery
well thank you for your attention and
thank you very much for coming please
join me in thanking professor Nelson
again and I'm sure you won't want to buy
her book and have it signed at this
point which you can do just at the back
thank you
[Music]
it's this one saying that he's written
in 1962 which had never been published
you know it's a kind of essay he'd
written now he was writing at that time
essays he wasn't doing his radio
commentaries yet but he wrote a lot I
mean it's one of the really surprising
things about rain probably wrote every
day of its life and he was a good writer
he wrote he wrote for the human voice he
wrote ads of someone who had developed
his early career on radio he wrote to
read not to be read on the page but he
was always writing these little essays
and commentaries and in this one written
in 1962 he says you know it's it's it's
possible that that communism will take
over and you know that will end in
nuclear war on conflict but you know
what I think it's more likely that
communism the Soviet Union will just
collapse said because he said communism
isn't and isn't even a political system
or an economic system it's just a form
of insanity he said it's a violation of
human nature it doesn't make any sense
nobody would want to live like that and
it's just you know in this essay and he
kind of plays this out you read this you
think wow that's a really interesting
view because people on the right didn't
think that then they didn't think
communism was gonna collapse but it was
sort of Reagan applying his common sense
perspective on anything on everything to
communism eise it doesn't make any sense
for people to live like that
nobody would tolerate it if they knew
how we live they they were they wouldn't
stand for it and he had this he had this
kernel of an idea that he held on to and
you find it repeated in various forms
when he starts to do these really
interesting radio commentaries in the
late 1970s which were the place he
really developed his political ideas
between his losing campaign for
president in 1976 when he challenged
Gerald Ford and his winning campaign in
1980 and that eccentric view matched up
with some other eccentric views he had
you Steve find also reading these
commentaries Reagan hated nuclear
weapons he'd been a path
fists he called himself a pacifist in
the 1930s partly it was he you know his
early involvement in theater he would go
to all these plays
he went to see when he was very young
like nineteen years old this play
journey's end which is a play about the
First World War but British play that's
kind of a pacifist play it's about the
waste of the First World War and the
poem you know the trench warfare and
these young men dying pointlessly that a
huge impact on it
another thing that had a huge impact on
him was when he was in the Second World
War
making training films in in Hollywood
but at a military base the the the base
was sent these early films of the
liberation of Auschwitz there's this you
know there's a myth thing that's total
entrance said about Reagan that he
claimed that he was one of the people
who lived liberated Auschwitz he never
said anything like that it's kind of
thing you can only believe if you don't
actually know the story of rape but he
did see in 1945 films of the emaciated
prisoners the piles of corpses and a
huge effect on him he actually Ron
junior remembers his father trying to
make him watch this years later because
he says you have to understand this
about humanity this is possible but that
was another thing that that influenced
this idea he had that the nuclear war
would be totally horrifying and
unacceptable and he thought especially
after he became president and the
assassination attempt that his mission
was to reduce the threat of nuclear
weapons and you know the the
conventional view the conservative view
is that well he had the strategy of
peace through strength came into office
big military buildup you know make the
Soviet Union Bank robbed forced them to
collapse and surrender I don't think
that's at all what happened if you look
at the record he was desperate for a
connection and negotiation with the
Soviet leaders in the Reagan Library you
can find these handwritten letters long
handwritten letters
you wrote to every Soviet leader when he
was president
starting with Brezhnev that Chernenko
Andropov jinyang Co fondly Gorbachev and
these letters they're really touching he
says you know he says you and I have the
power to destroy the world we also have
the power to save the world and make
peace and we have to be able to
communicate we have to meet we have to
talk to each other he was reaching out
to try to form a connection and he would
get back these letters that were in this
Leninist boilerplate about Western
imperialism and you know there's clearly
I mean stall these guys were dying we
now know one after the other but there
was he wasn't able to make any
connection and he was terribly
frustrated by that and terribly upset
about it and all the time the defense
build-up what's going on during the the
first term when it's a sort of heyday of
the neoconservatives and this hawkish
view of the world reagan's on board for
that but he's also really really unhappy
because he thinks the world is getting
more dangerous and when he finds out
basically from a CIA briefing that the
soviets actually think that the United
States might attack that that we have
aggressive designs on them he's shocked
how could they think that we would never
do that
and he I think in his second term didn't
continue that strategy he turned around